bien difficile déjà d'enlever la vitre
c'est quelque chose de très difficile
sans se blesser sans recevoir des
esclops visage je commence par chauffe
il a vite pour m'aider votre série
l'habite le plus facilement possible
donc une fois l'avis de chauffe et je
m'apprête à enlever la vie il ya des
câbles qui passe tout le tour de
l'appareil donc faut pas les endommager
maintenant on va enlever le lcd
on va de faire les captures glisse
enlever les séries pour pouvoir brancher
la seule nouvelle surface tactile
une fois la nouvelle surface tactile
installé
on va simplement remettre lcd donc ça
sur c'est bien collé tout haut du
boîtier et le travail était remis donc
c'est vraiment pas donné à tout le monde
de pouvoir réparer ce genre d'appareil